can we talk about nuclear weapons just
for a little bit so fission
is the kind of reaction that's central
to the nuclear weapons we have today
that's what sets them off that's what
sets them off
so if we look at the hydrogen bomb maybe
you can say how these different
weapons work so the earliest nuclear
weapons the
the nuclear bombs that were dropped on
japan etc etc
were pure fission weapons they used
enriched uranium or plutonium and
their energy is essentially entirely
derived from
fission reactions but
it was early realized that more
energy was available if one could
somehow
combine a fission bomb with
fusion reactions
because though fusion reactions give
more energy per unit mass
than uh than fission reactions
and these were this was called the super
you might have heard of the expression
the super or more simply hydrogen bombs
okay
um bombs which use isotopes of hydrogen
and the fusion reactions associated with
them
like you said it's hard to turn on it's
hard to turn on because you need very
high temperatures
and you need confinement of that long
enough for the reactions to take place
and so a bomb actually a thermonuclear
bomb
or a hydrogen bomb um
has essentially
a chemical implosion
which then sets off a fission
explosion which then sets off
and compresses hydrogen isotopes
and other things which i don't know
because i don't i've never had a
security clearance okay so i so i can't
betray any
secrets about weapons because i've never
been party to them but
because i know a lot about this problem
i
can guess okay um and and sets off
fusion reactions in the middle okay so
that's basically
it's that sequence of things which
produce these enormous you know
multi-megaton
uh bombs that have very large yields
um and so fusion alone can't get
can't get you there it is actually
possible
to set off or to try to set off
little fusion bombs alone without the
surrounding uh fission explosion
and that is what is called laser fusion
so another approach to fusion which
actually is
mostly uh researched in the
weapons complex the national labs and so
forth
because it's more associated with the
technologies of of weapons
is inertial fusion so if if you decide
instead of
trying to make your plasma just sit
there in this taurus and
in the tokamak and be controlled steady
state with a magnetic field if you if
you're willing to accept that
i'll just set off an explosion okay and
then i'll gather the energy from that
somehow i don't quite know how but let's
not ask that question too much
um then it is possible
to imagine generating fusion alone
explosions and and the way you do it is
you take
some small amount of deuterium tritium
fuel
you bombard it with energy from all
sides
and this is what the lasers are used for
extremely powerful at lasers
which compresses the pet the
propellative fusion
and heats it it compresses it to such a
high
density and temperature that the
reactions take place very very quickly
and in fact they can take place so
quickly that they're
it's all over with before the thing
flies apart
wow and that is heated up really fast
that is inertial
fusion okay is that useful for
energy generation not yet
i mean there are those people who think
it will be but you may have heard of the
big experiment called the national
ignition facility
which was built at livermore starting in
the late 1990s and has been
in operation since around about 2010.
it was designed in with the claim that
it would reach ignition fusion ignition
in this pulsed form where the reactions
have got over with so quickly before the
thing
whole thing flies apart it didn't
actually reach ignition and i
doesn't look as if it will although you
know we never know maybe people
figure out how to make it work better um
but the answer is in principle it seems
possible to reach ignition
uh in this way maybe not with that
particular laser facility
are you surprised that uh
we humans haven't destroyed ourselves
given
that we've invented such powerful tools
of destruction
like what do you make of the
the fact that for many decades we've had
nuclear weapons now
speaking about estimating risk at least
to me it's exceptionally surprising i
was born in the soviet union
that um that big egos
of the big leaders when uh rubbing up
against each other
have not created uh the kind of
destruction one was a
everybody was afraid of for decades well
i must say i'm extremely thankful that
it hasn't i don't know whether i'm
surprised about it
um i've never thought about it from the
point of view of
is it surprising that we've we've
avoided it i'm just very thankful that
we have i think that there
is a sense in which cooler heads have
prevailed at crucial moments
i think there is also a sense in which
you know
mutually assured destruction um has
in fact worked um as a policy
to restrain the great powers from going
to war
and in fact you know the the
the fact that we haven't had a world war
you know since
the 1940s is
perhaps even attributable to nuclear
weapons
in a kind of strange and peculiar way
but i think humans are deeply
uh flawed and sinful people
and i certainly don't feel gap that
we're guaranteed that it's going to go
on like this
you